how are you able to keep the end cost to
the consumer solo for what you're
delivering especially considering this
is the first run of the product I mean
shouldn't you keep costs higher to help
offset the production costs and all the
effort that it takes to get the fight to
the market well so one of the major
major primary reasons that this camera
came about in the first place was
because you know Joe is looking for a
raw shooting camera that existed under
ten thousand dollars and while there are
some incredible high-end cameras that
shoot raw there are not a lot of
consumer price cameras that can shoot
that type of footage and so that was a
big incentive in making this a sort of a
wider project rather than just a
personal project for the needs
camera for initially and so one of the
things that we've done to keep the cost
down is to use all off-the-shelf parts
rather than doing a lot of proprietary
design which many
camera companies do and there's
different reasons for that one of them
is so that you know they can create
custom accessories like batteries or
cards that could only work on their
camera we decided to do the opposite and
just get as much stuff off the shelf as
possible because that means that there's
a whole area rd that we don't have to do
we're going with with products that have
already been tested and we don't
figure out if they're going to function
in a way that we need them to and taking
parts off the shelf allows us to just
keep the cost way way way down the other
part of the is licensed free is off the
shelf and licensed free technology so
the only part of the digital bollocks
that we're going to pay a license fee
for is the HDMI port which wasn't in the
original specs and that's one of the
reasons it wasn't in the original specs
but when you deal with proprietary
software either designed by us or
designed by another company yet it
really puts the the price advantages in
the side of large companies but when you
deal with off-the-shelf parts
license-free technology some of the
price advantages actually fall to
smaller companies that have much less
overhead so we can't design a censor
ourselves because it would put our
product costs much much higher because
of the rd but if we use a good sensor
and make a good choice in sensors from
an off-the-shelf product we can offer a
camera at a competitive a lower price
because we have much less overhead and
the bigger companies and our other
business strategy is partnering and
we've partnered with bollocks we've
partnered with palm for the software
company we've come partnered with IM so
an electronics company in order to bring
all of these tools under one roof and
make the design process much cheaper
you